[Music]
with cases rising again
new variants are spreading and sadly
some of the reckless behavior we've seen
on television over the past few weeks
means that more new cases are to come in
the weeks ahead
i'm going to reflect on the recurring
feeling i have of impending doom
we have so much to look forward to so
much promise and potential of where we
are and so much reason for hope but
right now i'm scared
because cases are going up but
hospitalizations and deaths are going
down president biden and the cdc
director offering a grim outlook on the
state of the pandemic where does this
come from
our next guest argues his constituents
now know what to do and stay safe
as his state prepares to lift remaining
covet sanctions
restrictions i should say georgia
governor brian kemp ready to do it
governor you one of the quickest to open
up first after
the immediate shutdown almost a year ago
today why is now the right time to be
the 19th state
to go without a mass mandate
well morning brian thanks for having me
on we're really excited about
where we are right now in our fight
against cobot but as you just said
our economy has been reopened for the
most part
working to protect livelihoods too for
almost a year now
the sectors that we have left that have
been struggling or
like many around the country when you
think about the airline industry
business and tourism travel convention
center business
in georgia you know this time of year
all the way through the summer
our beaches mountains you know there's a
lot of hard work in georgians that
depend on those jobs and
businesses that depend on that revenue
and that's what we've got to reopen
our numbers uh in my conversations with
dr toomey
are in the right place to start doing
that so we're working that way
yeah i mean if business wants you to
wear a mask if you go shopping
go ahead wear a mask but you're not
going to mandate it from the state level
and that's the point people could also
use their own judgment do what they're
comfortable with or
you don't have to go to the movies you
don't have to go to costco
especially with everything they can
deliver today governor you're in the new
go ahead final thought on that well i
was just going to say you know we
haven't had a
statewide mass mandate ever the whole
pandemic we don't have one now but
people are doing the right thing
everywhere i go when people are shopping
they're being respectful wearing a mass
social distancing and getting people
vaccinated
that's how we come out of this and live
with it for however long it's going to
be
over the next several months or even if
it's years that's what we're going to
have to do but we can't
continue to be shut down people cannot
survive that a governor almost from the
day you had
on election day from stacey abrams still
not admitting that she lost
the governor's race you've been in the
eye of the storm so to speak and now
uh first allied and now you're kind of
warring with the former president united
states
and then you went out and looked at
where georgia was voting now that the
pandemic
hopefully is in a rear view mirror and
you made some changes and you signed
this into law
and here's some of the changes require a
voter a photo
for an absentee ballot limit time
to request absentee ballots ballot drop
boxes locations you can have one per
county unless the county's really big
replace the secretary of state as
election board chair with an appointee
allow election boards to replace
election officials in underperforming
counties
reduce the runoff election time
and bars outside groups from handing out
food or water in line first off
on that last one you can get
refreshments
you just don't want uh political
organizations to hand them out
it's up to the precincts to do it if
they want to do it correct
yeah that that's outrageous what people
are saying
and you can the political groups and
others non-profits whoever can still do
that brian if they're outside the 150
foot
buffer around the polling location or 25
feet from the end of the line
so it's not like you still can't do
those things we're just trying to keep
voters from being harassed and
electioneered
while they're standing in line preparing
to vote we've had laws like that and
most states have around the country for
years
but as you know hypocrisy is running
rampant right now this bill makes it
easy to vote and hard to cheat
i heard you mentioned on the tease
earlier that president biden got four
pinocchios
from the washington post which is
incredible because they're absolutely
right what he was saying is not true
and even more hypocrisy was stacy abrams
celebrating new jersey expanding the
nine days of early voting
when her own state of georgia has 17
and we just added more opportunities on
the weekend so they're being
mistruthful about what the bill does
right but they're out communicating you
because you have the facts on your side
it seems
even the washington post picked that out
first off the accusation from among
people the president united states
on the whole water thing as well as
other things listen
what i'm worried about is how unamerican
this whole initiative is it's sick
deciding that you're going to end voting
at five o'clock when working people are
just
getting off work well the washington
post heard that like you heard that and
this is what they figured out
biden falsely claims the new georgia law
ends voting
hours early it is not true
right your hours remain the same correct
yeah and a matter of fact we've got 134
out of 159
counties and this bill will actually be
expanding the number of hours that
people can vote in the process so what
he's saying is not true
but you know it leads to the question of
this is all just a distraction for them
to make a case to do an
unconstitutional power grab with hr1
and also to distract from the you know
talking about
water flowing there's a crisis of people
flowing across the southern border
uh you know perhaps we should pay more
attention to that than our
um genus voting times that we have in
georgia especially compared to his own
state of delaware
and what you're trying to do is if if
you don't have id you write a state
number in or your social security number
on that absentee ballot
and when it comes to drop boxes this is
the first time you're using them
you just don't want a lot of them you
want to put them in places
in in controlled places one per county
unless this county is really big
real quick on your on drop boxes yeah
the the other side's saying we're taking
that away there's actually counties that
didn't have drop boxes this
legislation requires every county to
have one so what they're saying again
is not true so governor if they're
calling you racist and they're and
they're saying you're trying to
not lock out you're trying to stop
people from voting and they're saying
minorities shouldn't vote
you have to have your communication out
team if you feel you have the facts and
it seems you do on your side
every day because it's it's relentless
and again they're putting georgia
in the boycott eye of the storm major
league baseball's pressuring
to get their all-star game out the pga
is getting pressured to move out the
masters
uh major corporation so it's up to you
to save them by communicating
uh what you're doing did 11 interviews
yesterday
getting an early start today we're
pushing it hard to get the truth out
there and the truth wins in the end as
you know absolutely governor thanks so
much